we've got the place to go if you are
looking for some late summer fun that's
right las vegas now's jc fernandez heads
to lake mead to show us the sport of
tubing in this week's vegas drives
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
swimming in the lake is a great way to
cool off but so is tubing on lake mead
and that's what we're going to do today
with our good friend bruce nelson bruce
it's always great to see you buddy yeah
it was great to see you thanks for
coming out again all right so tubing
okay let's talk about tubing what is it
do you guys rent the tube if someone's
watching they want to go tubing so yeah
you can't really rent two but you can
buy one you like start from you know 40
or 50 dollars up to a few hundred or
more depending on what you want to do
and it's just a great everybody can do
it you know grandma and grandpa the kids
mom and dad everybody can too that's the
great thing about your squad have a good
time um you need a boat you need a
couple people you need some life jackets
a ski flag and go have a good time tube
number one what is it we got just a
basic tube for one guy or gal the the
joby revolve one now the rules out there
if i want you to go faster or go slower
any hand signals i should have went out
there in the world you know you want to
go faster thumbs up slower thumbs down
you want to stop you know all right you
ready
here we go get it
[Music]
[Music]
there he goes outside the way finally
yeah you did good that time how fast
were you going oh we're doing what like
30 30.
yeah about 30 about 30 30. i feel like i
was doing 75. are those bathrooms
floating bathrooms oh is that what we're
towing next uh yeah we'll just put you
right here
thank you though i actually already went
i'm good too no i'm kidding i want to
know is that next we're doing that thing
that's our that's our next ride that's
the uh we'll call it the cone the cone
how many people does the code for and
we're just going to drag that thing
behind the boat drag that cone standing
up yeah okay four people one
two
lance here number three a photographer
and the fourth guy will be our spotter
yeah in the boat in the boat yeah how do
i get on this thing i just jump jumping
hold on man
that didn't work that was graceful
my turn yeah
go ahead first
now you okay here we go on the other
side
we made it
that was not easy i'm exhausted just
from getting on
this isn't to go well
water sports don't like mead
let's go okay
oh my god
oh
we're still hot we're still on
all now here we go here we go
whoa
whoa
all right next
step off